je suis la comtesse de mars et je suis
la gouvernante du petit enfant du
château de rambouillet celui qui
s'appelle louis jean marie de bourbon
penthièvre si rambouillet nous était
conté au château pendant les fêtes
direction de xviiie siècle la conteuse
émerveille petits et grands dès l'âge de
4 5 ans on reste dans un lieu historique
et j'aime alliés l'histoire la vraie
l'histoire de france et en même temps
les petites histoires amusantes pour que
ces lieux ne soit pas juste des lieux
d'histoire un peu poussiéreux mais que
ce soit vraiment d endroit vivant la
tradition le mot clé de ce rendez-vous
annuel du monument rambolitains avec
château des comtes le public renoue avec
l'histoire loin de certaines
superproduction dont on va toujours
mettre en avant la morale des fables le
fait que les comptes étaient utilisés à
l'époque pour apprendre des choses aux
enfants mais finalement s'il ya bien des
vacances et un moment où on va beaucoup
plus privilégié la féerie est juste le
plaisir d'être en famille d'écouté des
choses un peu merveilleuse et de
profiter d'un tel cadre c'est noël un
roi
c'est magnifique je me régale j'espère
autant que les enfants et j'aime bien
c'est drôle je viens j'aime surtout les
histoire
déjà j'aime beaucoup les pièces des
peintures et j'aime aussi bien les
histoires c'est charles perrault et bien
sûr l'auteur phare en cette période de
fêtes jeanne marie leprince de beaumont
moteur de la belle et la bête et jean de
la fontaine ne sont pas oubliés un
moment familial à partager pour
prolonger encore un peu ces fêtes de fin
d'année vous l'avez jeter